que ha contribuido a que la izquierda
logre consolidar una alianza tan grande
buenas tardes en la reconfiguración del
electorado durante la campaña
presidencial y en el examen presencial
ha permitido que emergiera un volume
fuerte a la izquierda liderado por su
primer oso y la falta de votos por el
partido socialista y por el partido
ambientalista hizo que en todos sus
partidos reconocieran el liderazgo del
numeroso entonces es un momento
histórico para el líder debe forzar su
mies para poder pues asumir un liderazgo
en la izquierda de las fuerzas políticas
del país ahora durante la primera vuelta
de las presidenciales se habló de una
derrota de la izquierda pero con esta
coalición como se proyecta hacia las
legislativas de junio
es probable que quien no gane en las
elecciones legislativas y generalmente
en francia por el sistema político un
apoyo al presidente electo en este caso
probablemente la mayoría del parlamento
va a apoyar al presidente marrón
entonces no no es probable una victoria
de la izquierda pero sí una
consolidación y probablemente un lema es
un proyecto de más largo plazo como se
conoció en los años 70 cuando la
izquierda logró unificarse para después
tener un solo candidato presidencial en
el 81 vídeo que logró ganar la elección
presidencial entonces yo creo que el
objetivo es a más largo plazo que esas
elecciones que ya vienen en las próximas
semanas es decir que no podría darse
entonces el proyecto de harlem elección
de convertirse en primer ministro
pero creo que es poco probable la verdad
ese es un eslogan de campaña es una muy
buena campaña para asumir el liderazgo
de la izquierda para asegurarse el apoyo
de los diferentes partidos de la
izquierda pero yo creo que la idea es
más a largo plazo crear una fuerza de
izquierda unida para poder en las
próximas elecciones presidenciales que
son generalmente en france a los sitios
democráticos más importantes y en caso
de que se logre una eventual victoria en
las urnas como se vería afectada la
gobernabilidad de manuel macrón
pues le tocaría cambiar pero yo creo que
de todos modos le va a tocar cambiar un
poco el estilo ha sido un presidente que
tenía apoyo de la mayoría del parlamento
y libros en unos nuevos parlamentarios
que no tenían digamos una fuerte
ideología entonces apoyaban el programa
del presidente de todas maneras va a
haber una reconfiguración y va a tener
que darle garantías a la izquierda
entonces es probable que haya un poquito
más de él por lo menos una política
menos neoliberal menos orientada hacia
las empresas y de pronto tomando más en
cuenta a las demandas de las poblaciones
que hemos visto en movimientos sociales
pero también en elecciones en los
últimos años en france